So I got out a textbook,
it was called race class and gender and
it's,
it's an anthology that's used in
cultural studies courses in women's
studies courses and it's Sorta the goto
texts.
So I'm told and I'm reading it and I
turned it and I would turn to page 14
and I can tell you it's page 14 because
I was so astounded by what I found and
it said,
uh,
we.
Oh,
it says objectivity as found through
rational thought is a western and
masculine concept that we will challenge
throughout this text.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
And I said it's too bad.
It's too bad that you're shocked by that
because the want to go for irrational pc
types have been saying exactly that
since the 19 seventies.
Like,
that is exactly.
Make no mistake about it.
This is why mcclachi is wrong.
This isn't,
this isn't something they're secreting
in.
This is the dead statement.
Oh yeah.
They said,
um,
the,
the whole notion of logic and coherence
and empirical data for that matter,
the very nature of evidence.
Let's question,
let's question the definition of
evidence because the underlying idea.
Remember,
the underlying idea here is that all
hierarchies are predicated on power,
so if the reason that I put forward
something as evidence isn't because it's
evidence,
it's because it's evidence that I get to
have that position of power,
and so if you're a postmodernist and you
say,
well,
I'm going to question your evidence,
what you think you're saying is you're
going to question my claim to that
arbitrary power.
The whole idea that there's evidence
outside of claims of arbitrary power.
The postmodernist dispensed without the
19 seventies.
That's Derrida.
That's exactly what he said it all.
This time I've been trying to get
samples of thousands so that I could
say,
this is a little bit.
We can say something God just in
generalized.
No,
no.
That just demonstrates how thoroughly
entrenched you are in the reining
patriarchal ideology,
I guess,
and I was just hoping to get beyond
anecdotal.
There's no beyond that.
There's no beyond anecdotal.
That's become a methodology.
That's audible.
It's called auto.
Ethnography is a technical term for it
and auto ethnography is the publication
of a journey of a,
of a private diary essentially in a
hypothetically reputable,
reputable academic journal.
It it's only because of in the last
three or four years that these things
have been happening and I said,
well,
where do they get this?
How do they,
how do they find these thoughts?
Yes.
Well,
we don't.
We don't want to fall into the mistake
of making,
of making the assumption that this
hasn't been thought through.
People are not just misunderstanding
what evidence is.
That isn't what's happening at all.
When they say they want to question the
definition of evidence,
that's exactly what they mean when they
say we want to question the definition
of evidence because the definition of
evidence currently supports the
scientific power structure in chemistry
say,
and that's fundamentally dominated by
let's say white men.
We can go after the definition of
evidence itself and that's how we're
going to bring it down and so the next
people on the hit list are going to be
the biologists.
They're already under attack from the
social justice.
It said that mathematics is whiteness,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
I didn't know that mathematics could
have a race.
Yeah,
but thing.
The thing is there's nothing logical
about these claims.
Once you accept this central axioms,
the axioms are straightforward.
The world is a battle ground of power
hierarchies.
That's what it is.
There isn't anything else outside of
that,
and each power hierarchy generates its
own internal narrative including rules
for what constitutes evidence that
support and buttress the structure of
that hierarchy and because the
hierarchy's exclude,
then it's in the best interests of the
people who are excluded to invert the
hierarchy,
and of course they also regard that as
just even though that's part of the
incoherence of the entire argument,
that's where they have to turn to to
Marxism,
but make no mistake about it.
This isn't.
This isn't accidental.
It isn't.
People misunderstanding what constitutes
evidence.
Not at all.